Elon musk's ownership of Twitter has
gotten off to a shaky start in his
latest controversial move he's banned
more than a half dozen Twitter accounts
mainly high-profile Tech journalists who
were reporting on musk's ownership of
the company some like Aaron rupper had
been critical of musk there does seem to
be a goal here to kind of put a chill on
negative coverage of him critical
coverage of him by sort of conveying to
journalists hey you know if you cross me
I can kind of take this all away from
you I can sort of banish you from this
platform that people in the media rely
on the ban had also extended to others
who hadn't been particularly critical of
musk I had a message which popped popped
up which said I was suspended then a
little bit later there was a banner that
came up that said I had been permanently
suspended and if I wanted to appeal it
to click on a particular link I clicked
on that link and it's a broken link late
Thursday musk briefly joined Twitter
spaces chat where he justified
suspending the journalists because he
claimed they doxed him meaning they made
public his live location or personal
information details
musk claims he wants to bring back free
speech to Twitter but Banning these
journalists seems to run counter to that
and up until now most of the talk has
been about the people that musk has
invited back on the platform many of
whom very controversial figures
like this far right troll account used
to make anti-semitic statements it was
suspended in 2007 for violating
Twitter's policy on hateful conduct but
musk reinstated it last week do I think
that it's going to necessarily make musk
Hemorrhage users at this point maybe not
is it incredibly damaging towards the
idea that somehow this is a free speech
absolutist we're moving towards more
free speech we're allowing more free
speech I think we're already seeing the
limits of what his own personal
definition of what that looks like is on
the platform
what's clear now is that Twitter is Elon
musk's own private platform where only
he decides who is allowed to tweet and
who gets suspended if they cross him
Gabriel lozondo Al Jazeera New York